what do you think about Star Wars coming
back again and and what would you like
to see happen if anything could happen
well this is there's there's so many so
conflicting stories going around i mean
there's even stories around saying that
the next films they're holding all these
auditions for are not even Star Wars
movies I mean that's just a story which
is going right now I mean they're having
these auditions all over the country and
I like they're nothing else but I've
been on radio and television you know
for the last couple of weeks you know
you know when they come on it because
because the first audition held in
Bristol which is my home city like you
know they all want to know what more
water was what it was like for AB
Rustoleum to be Darth Vader and so on
and so forth you know and then but now I
said before they've come out with all
sorts of our hotels so you know saying
that they don't need lots of in some
cases they said that they the cat
they're casting at the moment for two
characters I'm a male and a female but
they don't even know whether they're out
for the Star Wars movies so I mean this
I died on what's going on I mean this
strange really is yeah I mean if I'm
personally not obviously not going to be
involved you know I mean if it was Star
Wars knows you know and they're gonna do
seven eight nine of course I'm fortunate
I got killed off in six oh yeah so so
there's no hook there's no future for
Darth Vader I do but a bit of with a bit
luck I mean they're the good thing is it
could be a possible role for me and the
movie because i know i was never seen
facially so i got i could play the
handsome hero or something that is
if you could come back in Star Wars what
kind of character would you like to play
would you like take goody this time no I
don't like playing good is no I want to
play the batter you know I love playing
baddies yeah they're much more fun yeah
yeah so you'd want to be on the dark
side again yeah stay on the dog so idea
is that the darker the better yeah yeah
baby I mean I know Darth Vader was
killed off but they could always
reanimate him who knows what could
happen no I don't think so no he's dead
and buried yeah he's gone yeah forgot
city because it was such a popular
character I mean you know with the fans
I mean he still is I mean you know he's
probably the most popular care of all
the Star Wars characters and I know
they're probably find some somewhere
resurrecting him like you know yeah be
lovely yeah be nice what do you think
about stepping into that costume again
I'd love to I'd love to I'd love to do
it yeah well I after I thoroughly
enjoyed them and the episodes i was in
my name was a four or five six very nice
very nice experience you know I said
seven be nice working with you know JJ
Abrams oh I've never worked with before
I understand George is going to overlook
oversee the whole thing anyway and so
it'd be nice working with George Lucas
again and
you know i would i would love to i would
love to get rolling in the millions in
some shape or form i don't care whether
is playing Darth Vader or whether it
spend another character you know but it
would be nice it would be nice to have
an involvement I felt said it's quite
funny because you know people have been
ringing me up and they said well in or
what can you what can you attack what
can you tell the couple you know because
you're looking for a boy and a girl they
said what can you tell them what can you
tell the boy and the girl they can
expect I said well tell them it's a
life-changing experience you know it
really is i mean because I mean Star
Wars from me has changed my life
completely I mean my you know I do I
mean I do nothing else to travel all
over the world you know I'm somewhere
different in the world almost every
weekend and you get this fantastic
acclaim wherever you go so as I said it
to me times I mean to me it was really
life-changing yeah what kind of advice
would you give them a moan apart from
obviously is going to change your life
but what kind of tips would you tell
them to kind of cope with that whether
the first editions were held in Bristol
Zoo and i've been criticized everything
ever since ever since Star Wars came out
about my Bristol accent exactly we tell
when and what in the West Country you
you tend to over pronounce errors in our
as you say is a war on my dear and
English humor and I said and they said
I've had this thought in for the last
couple of weeks they said no what what
advice would you give you know to the
two people they were going to do they
are going to do these roles and I said I
said well the first thing is lose your
Bristol high street
I don't making it no they're mad about
anything else just lose your Bristol
accent look yeah courses loads of rumors
aren't there flying around at the moment
this room is the you know the gloomy
Harrison Ford and Carrie Fisher and Mark
Hamill going back as well and maybe even
Billy Dee Williams to and what do you
think about maybe those guys yeah what
do you think about those guys return oh
no I think I'm easily I think it'd be
lovely i think if they do I mean it yeah
they research you know they're all such
popular characters then yeah I said I'm
fortunate as I'm sorry I got killed up
and fortunate so I won't be coming back
what I said he knows i think is very
very nice part from darth vader
obviously who we love who your favorite
characters in a star wars world that
you'd like to see come back for the new
Syria I think Boba Fett was a great
character as well he was a very clean
and it's become a very very popular
character with the fans you know be nice
to see him i'd like i'd like to OBC
darth vader resurrect it and now i think
i could because i think the villains in
the movie became more popular within the
in the actual start of the main stars
yeah
you